my parents - New York City public school
educators moved my family to Staten
Island when I was seven months old over
the Verrazano Bridge when the Verrazano
Bridge got built so seeing this film the
king of Staten Island and seeing my
hometown and it really was it looked
great my hometown look great man my
hometown looked great in this film and I
and I felt like I knew every character
like I grew up with them all and the
acting is great writing is great and the
director of this film joining me right
now Judd Apatow here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Judd I am a legit
Staten Islander sir so I give this my my
stamp of approval I'm legit finally
Staten Island getting the respect it has
been denied well I mean there's there's
um there's Alyssa Milano Rick Schroder
wu-tang clan or has already called it in
the Larry Sanders Show which you know so
very well the Staten Island streetwise
troubadours is I think how he described
him to Larry in one episode so you know
I'm legit here and now this will colin
jost as well Colin who looks and sounds
nothing like anybody I grew up with as
opposed to many of the characters in
this film John well he clearly tilted
all of that accent out I used to have a
very strong Long Island accent which
disappeared after 30 years in LA because
when I first got here I look at videos
of me doing stand-up and I'm like and
it's gone it's gone well again it's it's
it's a great movie and let's discuss it
a little bit here it is it it's loosely
based on Pete's life Pete Davidson who's
in every frame of this film it seems and
he's terrific in it it's loosely based
on his life Jud I mean it's a fictional
story it's about what happens when you
know young man who's not really doing
well is a bit of a slacker
and he lost his father who was a
firefighter and now his mom played by
Marissa Tomei is skating for the first
time in a long time and she starts
dating another firefighter played by
Bill burr and who tries to get Pete to
get his act together and the story's not
true but it is the type of story
Pizza discuss a lot of the stuff that
he's been through in his life and if I'm
not mistaken buscemi he's got a some
firefighting history and his in his real
life too right yes he was a firefighter
in the 80s and Little Italy for four
years
oh my gosh before his acting career took
off and he has stayed very close to the
firefighting community he works at this
charity called Friends of firefighters
and he's amazing he mean he's been an on
the Sandler movie since the airheads
when I used to live with Sandler Stanley
did airhead and so oddly he's been on
our orbit for a long time and he's one
of our heroes Judd Apatow here on on the
Rich Eisen show and just a lingering a
bit more on this film Pete Davidson's
sister in the film Maude Apatow what in
the world is it like to direct your
daughter
Judd well I like it cuz I get the boss
around cuz he's 22 now she doesn't
really have to listen to me although we
have been in isolation yeah there for a
long time with her my other daughter
who's 17 and now we're not it's not even
like I'm a parent anymore really I'm
just like a weird roommate I'm like a
smelly strange man they live with and
you can't punish them like you kind of
you can't ground them because we are all
groundless at this point you know so we
just sit around drinking white cloth and
we're all so that's what it was like
directing your child is basically what
you're saying to force her to listen to
me since that just ended so long ago
she's great in it man the film's
terrific it really is judge so congrats
on that and then people can start
checking it out on June the 12th coming
up in a couple days from now it yeah it
really is it really is so what uh what
was it like directing LeBron James he
was fantastic in trainwreck
Judd he was two ready situations you
know you just wonder how fun
someone will be you know what what are
their acting skills like because you're
just taking a guess that you could get
something out of them right and then he
shows up he's so prepared his acting is
great and he's genuinely riotously funny
it's not a performance that I had to you
know try to squeeze out of him he was
riffing like a guy who had been doing
comedy and improv for the last ten years
well it it was annoying in a way I can't
play basketball you know so I don't like
that he can do what I do how do you wind
up in the role though did you get like a
word that LeBron wants to give this a
try and and and you're like alright well
we'll kick the tires on it and then
LeBron shows up and crushes it how did
that all come about to be what is that
you go who would be the best person that
ever could do it okay LeBron James has
bills best friend for no apparent reason
and then you think there's no way he'll
do it does anyone know LeBron right of
course I'd built it well he just hosted
SNL and he had a really good time and he
was really nice and funny so so then we
went out to lunch with him and we told
him about it he found it really funny
and then the you know the funniest part
for us is that he just had to hang out
with us for a week all day every day
and live in our strange comedy nerd
world and I think he really enjoyed
himself you could see it on screen that
he's having a black is and and he said
he getting killed like we would do
screenings and the place would explode
in laughter people really appreciated
his child he was dynamite he really was
is it any truth to the rumor that Chris
Rock was there feeding him lines is that
true because I came and did a pitch a
line or two I don't know if anything
made it but what was funny as we were
shooting the scene where he's playing
one-on-one with Bill Hader which really
made us laugh that you know the whole
idea was that when he plays with Bill he
doesn't hold back like he goes easy on
him and he's just destroying him and
hurting him and slamming on him but when
we were shooting it it's almost like the
whole city knew LeBron was there because
just people just started showing up from
all directions okay it was it was very
exciting it was you know you just you
felt the energy and the and the great
deserved
love for him judd apatow here on the
Rich Eisen show director producer
screenwriter the king of Staten Island
in theaters of you know our video under
man obviously with what's going on in
the world coming up on on Friday I just
went into my old theaters near you line
a couple of occasions I have crossed
paths with you and I'll repeat here what
what what I told you then your
documentary on Garry Shandling is one of
the most moving beautiful tributes I
have ever seen and I not implore enough
people to check it out certainly if
there is time on your hands to try and
see who he was what he was about and
maybe gain some inspiration what do you
think Gary would think about what what's
happening right now in the world judge
well Gary was very much a believer in
the idea that we're all in this together
and there's a thing in Buddhism that
they talk about called the illusion of
separateness that you spend your life in
this illusion that you're not connected
with everybody else but you really are
and you have to get over the illusion of
separateness and that is definitely the
case we all have to lift each other
lift each other up we have to be there
for each other we have to love each
other and that's the only way things get
solved is with all of us as one and I
think that's the same for all the civil
rights issues as well as how we protect
each other from kovat how we take care
of the climate we all have to be in it
it can't be every person for themselves
he was something else mad that I got a
chance to meet him a couple of times and
he could not have been nicer and more
giving on you know cuz I when I when I
cross paths with him and a mutual friend
said you guys should chat and I asked
him to take a look at this show this
talk show that that that we're on right
now and I said who better to give me
some tips on what what it should look
like or talk what I should talk about or
what it should look like spatially I
mean the the details that he gave me I
my
regret as he sent it to my NFL email and
there's a system that they did they
destroy the emails after six months I
don't have them anymore it killed it
just absolutely destroy he was beautiful
the things he would write in the
messages he would give me was amazing
job all has the emails were you know
they were only so funny and I remember I
I went to all my emails that he sent me
over the years when I passed away and
what I noticed was that every single
time in the in every email over decades
where I said hey can you read this for
me can you watch this for me can you do
this thing with me he said yes
every single time it just made me cry I
just thought wow he was just a hundred
percent there for me and yeah I mean I
get all worked up about it I just loved
it so much and I put out a book called
its Garry Shandling's book as I found so
many hilarious jokes and journal entries
and photos that if people are interested
in that they can check that out and the
doc is on HBO streaming so you could
still see it as I mean both of us have a
lot of time to film it's four hours and
that'll fill four hours or your day Judd
Apatow again the king of Staten Island
here on the Rich Eisen show no the
Yankees have an affiliate on Staten
Island and made it into your film yeah
you are a Mets fan though correct you're
a die-hard met fan well I'm a fan of the
Mets I was a kid and I used to go to see
Dwight Gooden and Darryl Strawberry when
I was a senior in high school and I went
to somebody the great Dwight Gooden game
those were festivals Jud those were fest
those were like circuses when he would
get on the mound and people would start
clapping with two strikes
it was unbelievable is how you describe
to people going to a baseball game where
every single pitch for the entire game
the place exploded the energy in those
like good and games was incredible I
remember seeing him throw one hitter or
two hitter against the Cubs that year
and I've never seen anything more
exciting and then I got to make a 3430
about so I did and yes and Darryl
Strawberry that is great stuff now what
just what do you do again again I know
you're from the New York City
metropolitan area and your new film is
about Stalin what do you do with a guy
from New Jersey who works on your show
who's known to exaggerate the truth a
little bit who claims to have started
the kay corner what do you say about
blames I have a New York Times article I
showed you guys my guy Mike del two folk
says he started the kay corner judge
that's pretty incredible he really says
that no I did not start it well I knew
the people that started I got by the New
York Times because of the guys that we
used to sit with us in the upper - it
did it left for credit okay I took over
Thank You jadoo you see he understands
what they stole I just say I'm a liar so
without you there was nobody hanging
backward k0 and we did that for the game
I think that was what we stayed for odd
you should have concluded him in your in
your 30 for 30 is basically what I'm
saying you know that was a big part of
my life those case it was exciting it
changed baseball people who did they did
that I guess it's in some ways they
still do it but then it was exciting
back then I don't know if it is it they
don't even let people play enough of the
game now to get this many strikeouts
exactly I know now that's now good and
it would be just like well third time
through the order against a left-hander
you know we'll put the shift on maybe or
we'll just take them out you know
they'll let the computer decide there
you go
thanks for the time thanks for the call
Congrats in the king of Staten Island I
could not recommend it any any any
better we're gonna we're gonna have bill
burr up next week oh yeah real quick ask
asking the poll question before before
we go we have about two minutes left
all right jet it's the anniversary of
The Sopranos finale today yeah so we're
asking everyone do you think the Members
Only jacket guy killed Tony at the end
yea or nay I have to say this I am a big
fan of that ending I think that time has
proven that David Chase was correct I
think it's a it's almost a religious
type of ending which is it doesn't
matter where you end it it doesn't
matter that that's that was the light it
doesn't matter if he got killed that day
or didn't get killed just it's a it's
the emptiness
like a Buddhist expression so I say
there's no way to ever know it was a
hand of what what is the sound of one
hand clapping guys you know what I'm
saying radio show you must have an
opinion there is no greater there is no
nuance in this and in this medium jag är
neg you vote for what you think he's
dead or not we shouldn't celebrate like
hey now take care there's judd apatow
see how to force it out of them
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here